hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my Westworld season 1 episode 10 top
moments and what they all mean video
major spoiler warning if you haven't
watched the entire first season in
Westworld then this video will
definitely ruin it for you as mentioned
I'm going to do this a little bit
differently I'm going to go over the top
moments here all the reveals what it all
seems to mean and then I think I'm going
to do a Q&A but I'll talk about that
more later at the end of the video for
now let's jump right into it so overall
I was really satisfied with everything
that went down in this we had this tease
of Dolores and Teddy with Ford looking
over their shoulder which was a hint of
what his new narrative was but it was
also a big redirect anyways the first
big moments of the episode where Dolores
is origin you know what we saw her
actually come to life for the first time
and then Teddy's glitch when he glitches
out coming off of the train in
retrospect we can realize that he is a
big part of this story and the way
things are going to end up at the end of
the episode it was really cool to see
burne Arnold with the brand-new Dolores
and the special effects were awesome
like it really looked like her whenever
she sat up just you could actually see
through the mechanical parts the second
big moment was that the man in black
does own the park and oh yeah he is
William this wasn't a big surprise but
we did get to see the full
transformation including the early days
when he made it to the edge of the park
on his first visit we learned that this
whole idea of being reborn in the park
actually applies to his outside life his
trip there is what made him the man that
he is and brought him all his power and
wealth and everything else that he got
after he left there I mean he basically
schools Logan right off the bat whenever
he realizes what he could be outside of
the park the actual reveal was pretty
heart-wrenching in some ways you know we
got to know this guy William so well and
then when we see him pull back up into
town well it kind of makes sense based
on the way that the heart works so he
reveals this to Dolores and that sends
her to the next level as he's pushing
her for more information about the maze
we get the big next awesome moment the
maze is actually just something that was
based off arnold son's favorite toy it's
pretty poignant if you think about it
because suffering is the missing part of
his original pyramid of consciousness
like if you think about what Ford was
drawing on the board that was his whole
thing was he didn't know what was at the
top it was actually suffering we learned
that he was really trying to lead the
Loras to listen to her own voice because
that is what would define her
consciousness his idea bootstrapping
consciousness was to use his voice to
guide her to hearing her own the maze
really wasn't made for people not this
maze anyways Arnold explains it as not
being a pyramid but a journey inward I
know some people out there going to
probably be let down by this reveal but
I thought it came off great and it's
even better when you think about how
Ford co-opted this as a way to keep the
man in black busy the entire time while
he was setting up his endgame just as
the maze was only a toy rather than some
big structure that you had to find her
way through the maze in the present
timeline was just a fool's errand to
keep Dallas's majority shareholder the
man in black / William chasing his tail
we had doubts about whether Bernard
would pop back up or if he would just
stay off-screen until the end of season
1 but we found out that good old Byrne
Arnold is a still a key player in Ford's
new narrative May founds him where he
fell and when she wakes him up he's
surprised that he can actually remember
she says here you are finally awakened
your only wishes to go back to sleep he
tells her this isn't the first time that
he's woken up and perhaps more
importantly it's not the first time she
woke up either as a viewer this is when
I really was just like hell yeah this is
all going to be good the face she makes
and then the struggle that she has about
whether she'll ever be able to not
question her reality it was just
freaking perfect so that was the next
big moment it was that Maeve's actually
been awake before and her current path
had already been laid out beforehand
someone using Arnold's login credentials
has set up everything gee I wonder who
could actually have Arnold's login
credentials we'll talk more about that
later but what grabbed me about her
journey is the overwhelming desire for
her to believe she was in control
Bernard seems to be strangely at peace
with what's going on
and he digs a little deeper into the
code to show her that the narratives
already been laid out he's about to tell
her how the steps are all going to
finish up but instead she just breaks
the tablet this added a lot of suspense
to the idea and you kind of saw Felix
open up his tablet on the way out and at
the time I wondered if he wasn't just
checking out what's going on
I'd say by at the end it's not clear
whether Felix was actively being told
what to do by dr. Ford or if he was just
being influenced by some crazy magic
that old wizard guys like Ford can
actually pull off before we even got
downstairs we got a great moment where
armistice became the ruler of this
episode up to this point her story's
been pretty restrained but here we get
to see this great bit of acting like
there's so many points in just their
little trip around the building that are
instant classics and although everyone
was great it was armistice show for sure
the giggle whenever she first shoots the
automatic weapon and then of course when
she says that the gods are [ __ ] after
they take a bunch of them out then we
also got another big moment samurai
world I don't know about you guys but I
saw whenever they made that turn this
strange logo and I'm like man what is
that you know like it didn't obviously
didn't click in my head that it was
going to be sw4 Samurai world but I knew
something big was coming up around the
corner and there we have it there's more
worlds how many worlds we don't really
know are they all controlled by Ford we
really don't know but it is interesting
and that leaves a lot that we can learn
about this little structure in the
future the next big moment was what
happened at the beginning of the park
the real story
the truth that was the story behind what
we've been waiting to find out about
this guy named Wyatt the first critical
breakdown of the hosts at the park and
actually what part Arnold played and why
he pulled the strings the way he did so
that he could set up his own demise now
in the telling of the episode it's
pretty straight forward he starts to
believe that the hosts are capable of
consciousness so that this is a bad idea
to open the park and when he takes the
idea to Ford for basically says he's
going to keep moving on with the project
so Arnold comes up the idea that he's
going to have Dolores kill all the
and then him and we see it play out
exactly like that this whole idea of why
it is it based exactly on Dolores and
what she did before the park opened and
Arnold wasn't trying to live on through
artificial intelligence or some sort of
artificial intelligence that Ford had
developed but actually he was just a guy
who was completely devastated by the
loss of the of a son he tried to
recreate that in Dolores who is
basically immortal but in the end it
wasn't enough to quiet his pain so the
final moment and really the biggest
twist is that dr. Ford is not a bad guy
we learned that when he lost Arnold he
realized something about himself and it
took him a long time to be able to
figure out how to sort out these hoes so
that he could actually do what his
partner was trying to do at that time he
was trying to set them free and from all
the comments and questions and different
things that I've read in our
conversations in the comments of my
videos and on the forums and everything
else no one really nailed this I mean I
guess someone probably did somewhere but
I didn't read it and I read a lot of
stuff about the show and a lot of the
different theories so if you're that guy
and you're sitting there watching say no
no no I had it right well no offense I
just didn't read that particular post
Ford is not a bad guy you know I had
mentioned this a couple times in
previous videos about how he's trying to
improve on humanity not recreate it or
or create just garden-variety
consciousness he sees humans for what
they are they're very flawed even though
they're the top of the food chain he was
trying to write a different story
altogether
he tells Bernard that you know he needed
the time that they needed the time the
hosts need to be in Westworld for this
amount of time to understand their
adversaries and once he drops the
reveries in and they wake up in this
version i mean it's obvious that they've
woken up several times I guess things
just finally got to the place where he
feels like he could let them roam free I
mean I think it was pretty obvious when
Arnold asked her who's voice she should
follow way back in the episode that
that's what he was trying to do before
he explained it Ford was just continuing
that
on but at the same time giving them a
way to actually do something other than
just get reset or shut down by humanity
and that's the part that I missed
whenever I was talking about him trying
to improve
I always thought his motivations were
self-serving not that he was actually
trying to free them so you know the idea
was there that he could actually you
know that he was actually trying to make
a better version like when he talks
about Barnard being the perfect partner
and things like that and that's where I
think a lot of the other things that I
heard about him trying to get the host
together was you know to defeat the
board or to do this I haven't heard any
that said he was trying to get them to
this enlightened space where they could
actually be on their own in the end he
provided them with a place to do
everything that they needed to do by
getting the board to come there and then
wiping them all out these hosts now have
free range at least over this part now
we don't really know where this goes but
that makes things really cool to you
know speculate about whenever we think
about season two and beyond I mean it
really was a satisfying ending I mean
the man in black getting shot and being
like hell yeah it's about time something
like this is going on was just I mean it
was pretty freakin awesome than you
think so
and then for dying doesn't really mean
anything when you think about it
Arnold died and while you know it wasn't
this big thing of where he was going to
be like you know living in the code and
controlling everything
Ford did have his memory live on and
sort of development live on through
Barnard I don't think it's safe to say
that Ford or some version of Ford won't
be involved in the story moving forward
I would venture to say that maybe what a
part of that whole thing of taking
thirty five years was developing these
hoes so that he could actually have a
perfected vessel for himself to live out
his own immortality you know that's just
completely in the weeds right now but
just think about that I mean it's
definitely possible which is awesome so
there's a lot of stuff that we don't
know but for the most part we got what
we needed you know we don't know where
else seeing stubs are but I'm just going
to say that they wouldn't have brought
them into the story so just to have them
not be important sometime down the road
so they're definitely coming back you
know one way or the
other I'm assuming that Peter Abernathy
was out there in the field getting ready
to murder all the humans like the rest
of the cold storage people but that's
kind of a question mark too
I mean obviously Lee went down there to
set him free but there's also the
possibility that Charlotte didn't trust
him to do it so once he made the changes
she went ahead and expressed that out of
the park as well that could lead to some
really interesting retaliation later on
when it becomes hosts versus hosts of
course there's that other idea we'll all
the hosts that are still there work
together I don't think that Maeve's
being set up as a room faction and even
though Dolores is like terminator right
now I think that only extends to like
offing everyone that would be a
potential threat a human potential
threat within the park it's worth
mentioning that we didn't see any of the
people die we saw the lawyer shoot a lot
of random people but after I was
thinking about it there's definitely
some reasoning behind her keeping some
of them alive I think if they would have
killed the man in black off we would
have seen it as a big moment within this
finale so maybe that's just where things
will pick up in the beginning of the
next season but at least for now I'm not
considering Charlotte or the man in
black or anyone else to be dead if we
didn't see them actually die on screen
so let me know what you guys think were
you happy I thought it was great it they
really hit the the points that people
were picking apart about it you know the
whole idea that Ford plans Maeve's thing
the whole time I mean I've seen tons of
critical comments about how Maeve
storyline was terrible on how it was
ruining the show and other crazy stuff
like that and you know it's good to see
that there was a you know there was a
purpose behind everything she did it
wasn't just an entertaining thing to
watch while everything else was going
down so like I mentioned at the
beginning I was thinking about doing a
Q&A so if you have questions about this
episode in particular and also about the
whole season you can leave those in the
comments and then I'll do a Q&A in a day
or two after I get something to work
with I doubt I'll do a see my scene for
this because it's just pretty conclusive
so I think what I'll do instead is do
like an overview of the whole season or
overview of the ending what we can
expect to maybe think about in them
before Season 2 comes out your feedback
and inputs important to those so let me
know what you guys want to see me do
before I finish I just want to say that
you know the show deserves a lot of
credit the acting the writing the
concept the story you know I remember at
the beginning of the season I had this
idea like after the first episode was it
was really hard to feel connected to
these characters I mean we knew that
they weren't real and it's amazing to
think at the end you know like how how
real they actually have become whenever
you hear the lawyers deliver Wyatt's
line she does it twice she does it once
whenever she's talking to the man in
black and then once when she's talking
with Teddy right before she walks up to
kill dr. Ford I mean it's just perfect
the whole idea with Maeve you know
having free will at least as far as I
think she has a choice of whether she
stays on the train or not at that point
because the rest of the plans already
been done I just think they did a really
good job of developing these characters
and it was a lot of fun to watch let me
know what you guys think in the comments
make sure you like the video check out
the faces on these guys that's on the
scene that I put in the background here
it's just got your your Teddy your
Bernard your man in black but yeah
please subscribe to my channel I'm not
sure where we go from here I'm going to
do a lot of Westworld stuff in the
downtime between seasons but we're gonna
have to play it by ear
in the meantime I'll be going back to a
full schedule a game of Thrones until
another show comes along and we can get
into that thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon